Deku is the most idealistic altruistic
and self-sacrificing hero that you will
ever meet he literally wants to save
everyone even the villains but what if I
told you that he could have turned into
a villain if one specific part of the
story was changed what you don't believe
me you don't think Deku could ever
become a villain well I made an entire
full-length video on how Deku could have
become a Dark Avenger and a ruthless
dictator if the Battle of jakku turned
out differently than it did in the
original timeline I even got
professional voice actors to voice Deku
and other characters in the video check
it out right now Link in the description
and in the pinned comment you might
think I'm crazy now but I bet that video
will change your mind